TOM: Hi, I'm Tom.
MATT: And I'm Matt.
And today we're trying to break as many laws as possible.
TOM: Now there are two rules. Number one, the laws have to actually be in force.
None of this ridiculous "shooting a Welshman with a crossbow
in the bounds of York" nonsense.
MATT: And rule two: they have to be silly.
♪ I see you drivin' round town with the girl I love
♪ and I'm like, f-- ♪
[WIND NOISE]
[VAGUE SCREAM]
Ayyyyy!
[GIGGLING]
♪ We flew a kite in a public place
♪ We flew a kite in a pu- ♪
MATT: 192, 193, 194...
Tom, this is a pretty reasonable law.
I don't want my house blown up by a cannon(!)
[KNOCKING]
TOM: Legal. Legal. Le--
Illegal! Illegal. Illegal.
For this to count, the salmon needs to be used in the commission of a crime.
Ow! What the... what was that?
MATT: Assault and battery(!)
What do we do now?
TOM: Handle it.
That's... that's not nice.
♪ We flew a kite in a public place... ♪
[Translating this video? Add your name here if you'd like credit!]